Okay. Um, an interesting counterpoint
to the apocalyptic literature. Um,
and the apocalyptic reliance on God's
cataclysmic consummation of history in
order to dole out
justice to the righteous.
And the wicked is found in the book of
Esther. And this is a short novella.
It's set in fifth century. Persian was
probably written in the fourth century,
we think,
but it's set during the reign of Xerxes
and there's no x in the Hebrew alphabet.
This is a hush hush,
which is Cirque sees. Um,
and he was a fifth century Persian
emperor from about 46 to four 65,
and it's another heroic fiction that
features a Jew in the court of a gentile
king.
So it's like Daniel and the Jews of Persia
are threatened with genocide and they
are saved not by divine intervention,
but entirely through their own efforts.
Uh,
indeed,
the book of Esther does not mention
God once and the story revolves around
Mordecai.
Mordecai is a pious Jew.
He sits at the gate of the Persian
king, Akash Bay, Rocher Xerxes.
And his beautiful niece is
also central to the story.
Of course it's Esther and
he's adopted her as his own.
There's a lot of comic irony in this
story. It really is a fun read. Um,
time is not going to permit me to go into
the various sub plots and the dramatic
reversals, the, the
ironies and twists. Um,
but I will just highlight a few of the
most salient points that are relevant to
the conversation we've been having.
So when the Persian king
divorces his wife Vashti,
because she refuses to appear in the
Royal Diadem before the his mail courtiers
presumably, and nothing but the
royal diadem a esters, great beauty,
commend her to the king
and she becomes queen.
Now her uncle Mordecai advises her to be
discreet about her Jewish identity for
safety sake. He says in two
verses 10 and 11, it says,
Esther did not reveal her people or her
kindred for Mordecai had told her not to
reveal it every single day,
more to high would walk about in front
of the court of the Harem to learn how
Esther was fairing and what was happening
to her. So a little while later,
the king promotes a certain Haman.
Haman,
the aggregate to the post
of chief administrator and
everyone in the palace gate
kneels down to Haman as the king has
ordered everyone that is except for a
mortified. And Day after day he refuses.
And finally the matter is told to Haman,
this is chapter three,
verses four to six.
And when they spoke to him day after day,
and he would not listen to them,
they tell speaking to Mordecai
and he won't listen to them.
They told Haman in order to see whether
Mordecai's resolve would prevail for he
had explained to them that he was a Jew.
When Haman saw that Mordecai
would not kneel or bow low to him,
Haman was filled with rage,
but he disdains to lay
hands on more to high alone,
having been told who Mordecai's people
were Haman plotted to do away with all
the Jews, Mordecai's people throughout
the Kingdom of [inaudible] Roche.
So Haman cast lots a lot.
The word for lots is Purim.
So he casts lots in order to
determine the date of the massacre
Purim.
Uh,
and then he offers the king a handsome
bribe in return for permission to kill
the Jews of the kingdom. This is
chapter three, verses eight through 11.
And listen to the rationale that's
proposed. He says to the king,
there was a certain people scattered
and dispersed among the other peoples in
all the provinces of your realm whose
laws are different from those of any other
people and who do not
obey the king's laws.
And it is not in Your Majesty's
interest to tolerate them.
If it please Your Majesty, Let an edict
to be drawn for their destruction.
And I will pay 10,000 talents of silver
to the stewards for deposit in the Royal
Treasury there upon the king,
removed his signet ring from his hand
and gave it to Haman, the son of Hamata,
they aggregate the foe of the Jews and
the king said the money and the people
are yours to do with as you see fit.
So He provides a rationale and it also
provides a good bribe along with it to
get this edict.
So this edict goes out to every province
to destroy massacre and exterminate all
the Jews, young and old children
and women on a single day.
This is to be the 13th
of the month of Adar.
Jews everywhere began to fast
and weep and wail. They mourn.
They wear sack cloth and ashes and Esther
sends to Mordecai for an explanation
of the, of the commotion, right?
She's somewhat sealed off here in the
Harem and doesn't quite know what's going
on.
So he sends a message informing her of
the decree and the urges her to appeal to
the king and to plead for her people.
And Esther hesitates partly because it,
uh,
to appear unbidden before the King
carries a penalty of death and modify
responds with this message.
It's as Esther four 13 being 16.
Do not imagine that you have all the Jews
will escape with your life by being in
the king's palace. On the contrary,
if you keep silent in this crisis,
relief and deliverance will come to the
Jews from another quarter while you and
your father's house will perish.
And who knows,
perhaps you have attained royal
position for just such a crisis.
And then Esther sent back
this answer to Mordecai.
Go assemble all the Jews who live in shoe,
Sean and Susa and Persia
and fast in my behalf.
Do not eat or drink for three days,
night or day.
I and my maidens will observe the same
fast and then I shall go to the king,
though it is contrary to the law. And
if I am to perish, I shall perish.
So Mordecai went about the city and
did justice. Esther had commanded him.
It's a very tense scene. Esther
approaches the king and he has, you know,
you get a signal, he raises
his stepdaughter or not and
uh, to accept you or not.
And then this tense moment,
you know,
he permits her entry and he
offers to grant her every request.
And so she asks that the king and Haman
attend a banquet that she's preparing
and at Esther's request,
um, at Esther's banquet, uh,
the king offers to grant Esther any
request that she might wish to make.
And so her request is stated
in the following terms,
terms that show her loyalty to her people.
Esther seven three B through six.
If your majesty will do me the favor
and if it pleases Your Majesty,
Let my life be granted me as my wish
and my people as my request for we have
been sold my people and I to be
destroyed, massacred, and exterminated.
Had we only been sold as
bondmen and bondwomen as slaves,
I would have kept silent. For the
adversary is not worth the king's trouble.
And there upon King Alqosh Vevo, Roche
demanded of Queen Esther, who is he?
And where is he? Who dared to do
this? The adversary and enemy replied,
Esther is this evil Haman
and Haman cringed in terror
before the king and Queen.
So Esther boldly reveals her
Jewish identity before the king.
She expresses her solidarity in her
speech with phrases like we and my people
and I. And in the, there's a real
comedy of errors that follows a,
the king leaves a room in a rage and
Haman falls prostrate on Esther's couch to
beg for his life. And so when the
king reentered enters the room,
he sees Haman in this
compromising position,
and he declares does he mean to
ravish the queen in my own palace?
So he orders Haman to
be impaled on the very,
a steak that a Haman had set up for
Mordecai. Uh, and Mordecai in fact,
is then elevated in Hayman's
stead within the court.
But the Jews are still in danger because
an edict of the kings cannot be revoked.
Once a word has gone forth from the
king, it his law. So the solution is,
is second edict in which a Vedros charges
the Jews to arm and defend themselves.
And so then we have another of
many reversals in this story.
What was to be a day of
defeat and massive curve.
The Jews becomes a day of triumph as the
Jews who would now have permission to
arm themselves and fight, slay those
who were bent on murdering them.
The victory celebration,
which is the festival of Purim,
is commemorated by Jews to this
day. Um, the very melodramatic,
a story, uh, of this luxurious
Persian court life, uh,
and all of the attendant political
intrigue that goes on in the story.
It's recreated in annual per,
I'm celebrations,
very Rawkus carnival like dramatizations.
Um,
according to the Talmud on Purim,
it's a Mitzvah which can be in the
commandment or a good deed to get so drunk
that you can't distinguish between
more to high and Haman. Uh,
but for all of that,
there are some very important and
striking themes in this story. First,
there's the ethnic element of Jewish
identity rather than religious that comes
to the fore. In the book of Esther,
the presentation is secular.
The Jews are described as a people,
an ethnos.
Esther is fully assimilated
to her gentile environment.
Unlike Daniel who prays towards Jews,
Jerusalem daily in the court of the king
and observes the dietary laws in the
court of the king, we hear nothing
like this about Esther at all. Um,
there's also a very human and very
anti apocalyptic message in this story.
It gives expression to the conviction
that solidarity and heroic resistance are
necessary in the face of overwhelming
anti-Jewish aggression to ensure Jewish
survival. This, according
to the book of Esther,
so different from the book of Daniel is
the lesson to be learned from Israel's
history.
And if the book of Esther presents one,
a alternative to the post [inaudible]
eschatology in which you always enemies
are afflicted and consumed
for their wickedness,
then the book of Jonah
offers another perspective.
The book of Jonah is actually found
among the section of the Bible called the
profits. The second, the second section,
the prophetic books of the Bible. Um,
and that's because in the book
of Kings Second Kings 1425,
we have someone identified as Jonah,
the son of Amittai, um, the profit.
And so Jonah, this is this considered,
this is the same Jonah. And so it's,
the book is considered to be
among the books of the prophets,
but it differs insignificant ways
from the other prophetic books.
It is not in fact a collection of
Oracle's, it's actually a story,
somewhat comic story, a comic tale
about a reluctant prophet named Jonah.
I'm the second interesting or unusual
thing about this book is that Jonah is
commissioned by Yaffe way to carry
a message to the people of Nineveh,
the capital of Assyria,
not to the people of Israel.
These are light concept of divine
mercy receives its full expression.
In the book of Jonah,
in the first chapter,
Jonah receives a call from Yahweh
who instructs him to go to Nineveh,
who's wickedness is great and to
proclaim God's judgment. Chapter one,
the first three verses the
word of the Lord came to Jonah,
son of Amittai go at once to Nineveh,
that great city and proclaim judgment
upon it for their wickedness has come
before me. Jonah, however, started out to
flee to Tarshish from the Lord's service.
That's like saying he got up and went to
Timbuktu Tar. She, she was the extent,
the farthest extent of the known world
navigable through the Mediterranean.
So it's rather comic go to Nineveh
and he got up and went in the opposite
direction as far as he could. Uh, he, he
tried to flee from the Lord's service.
He went down to Joppa.
Yeah. Um, Jaffa. Yeah.
AAFA and found a ship going to Tarshish
and he paid the fare and went to board
to sail with the others to Tarshish
away from the service of the Lord.
So he does this immediate about,
about face in a very comic
touch and set sail for Spain,
the other end of the Mediterranean.
But of course,
Jonah cannot escape from
God and God sends a storm,
which threatens to destroy the
ship. The non Israelites, soldier,
sailors onboard,
prayed to their gods.
And then finally they cast lots
in order to discover who it is,
who's brought this danger to the ship.
And the lot falls to Jonah.
So Jonah confesses that he's a
Hebrew who worships the Lord,
who as he now realizes,
made both land and sea.
And that is a fact that strikes great
terror in the heart of the sailors when
they hear this, that
his god is, yeah, way.
And Jonah further adds that he's
trying to flee from God's service.
And the clear implication is that he
is the cause of this terrible storm.
So Jonah proposes that he'd be
thrown overboard to save the ship.
The sailors strive mightily to battle
the storm. But finally in despair,
they pray to God.
Yeah,
way to forgive them for
killing an innocent man,
and they heave Jonah
overboard and save the ship.
Now the sailors are said by
the narrator to revere God.
They offer a sacrifice to him.
They make a vows.
Now in the meantime,
God has appointed a huge
fish to swallow Jonah.
And so preserve his life and
from the belly of this fish,
Jonah prays to God.
The prayer or the psalm is not entirely
appropriate to the narrative context.
It's probably an insertion in
the story by a leader writer.
It's an insertion that
was probably suggested by
references within the prayer to
drowning in the deep,
to crying out to God from the belly of
Shea all and Jonah's in the belly of the
fish. So that linguistic resonance
may very well have been what, um,
prompted someone to insert this
prayer here. And in any event,
in response to Jonah's prayer,
God orders the fish to spew Jonah
out onto dry land. In chapter three,
Johnny gets his second chance.
God calls him again.
And in contrast to his
first response this time,
Jonah sets out for Nineveh at once
and he proclaims God's message.
In 40 days,
Nineveh will be overthrown and then comes
the the shocking element in the story.
Chapter three verses five to 10
the people of Nineveh believed God.
They proclaimed a fast and great
and smaller, like put on sackcloth.
And when the news reached the king
of Nineveh, he rose from his throne,
took off his robe,
put on sackcloth and sat in ashes and
he had the word cried through Nineveh by
decree of the king and his nobles.
No Man or beast of flock or herd shall
taste anything they shall not graze and
they shall not drink water.
They shall be covered with sackcloth,
man and beast and shall
cry mightily to God.
Let everyone turned back from his evil
ways and from the injustice of which he
is guilty. Who knows, but
that God may turn and relent.
He may turn back from his wrath so that
we do not perish. God saw what they did,
how they were turning
back from their evil ways,
and God renounced the punishment he had
planned to bring upon them and did not
carry it out.
So idolatrous Nineveh believes God and
humbles itself before God hoping to
arouse his mercy.
And in another humorous touch,
we read that even the animals
are wearing sackcloth, right?
They're fasting and crying out to God.
So from the greatest, to the very least,
the inhabitants of Nineveh turn back from
their evil ways and God's mercy is in
fact aroused. The Assyrians are
spared and Jonah is furious.
Chapter four verses one through four
this displeased Jonah greatly and he was
grieved. He prayed to
the Lord saying, oh Lord,
isn't this just what I said when
I was still in my own country.
That is why I fled beforehand to
Tarshish for I know that you are a
compassionate and gracious God. Slow
to anger, abounding in kindness,
renouncing punishment. Please Lord, take
my life. I would rather die than live.
The Lord replied, are you that deeply
grieved? Jonah doesn't respond.
He just leaves the city to Sulk.
And his complaint seems to be two fold.
If you're going to punish the wicked,
then just punish them.
They deserve it and if you're
planning to spare them,
then just spare them and don't waste
my time with messages and oracles,
but the stronger problem for Jonah's
seems to be the lack of punishment for the
wicked.
Joan is indignant that the Syrians didn't
get what they so richly deserved and
didn't I say this would happen.
You always forgive your this slowed anger,
compassionate guy. You'll always
repent. The wicked are never punished.
I'm fed up with the way you do things.
God,
your mercy perverts your justice and
some things ought not to be forgiven.
People must be held to account
for their evil actions.
How can God not do justice?
Jonah sits in a little booth that he
has constructed and God causes a leafy
plant to grow over him.
Providing shade and saving him from a
good deal of discomfort and the plant is
to be the source of a
final lesson for Jonah.
Jonah four six through 11 Jonah
was very happy about the plant,
but the next day at dawn,
God provided a worm which attacked
the plant so that it withered.
And when the sun rose,
God provided a sultry east wind and the
sun beat down on Jonah's head and he
became faint and he begged for death
saying I would rather die than live.
And then God said to Jonah, are you
deeply grieved about the plant? Yes,
he replied so deeply that I want to die.
Then the Lord said,
you cared about the plant which you did
not work for, and which you did not grow,
which appeared overnight and
perished overnight and should not.
I care about Nineveh,
that great city in which there are more
than 120,000 persons who do not yet know
their right hand from their
left and many beasts as well.
How can you halfway not be compassionate
for even the most evil of peoples are
no less his creation and he has
cared for then precious Israel.
And if they will only turn to him and
humility, he'll wipe the slate clean.
He'll show compassion and forgive.
It is only human to long for
the punishment of the wicked.
But God longs for their re formation.
They're turning.
The date of the book of Jonah
really can't be ascertained.
And you will hear arguments in both
directions. Many scholars data at late,
others suppose that the story is at
least at base and old, old story,
Nineveh appears as another Saddam.
Basically,
it's a story that is in keeping with
that older Torah tradition in which,
uh,
it's assumed that God
punishes non Israelites or
other nations for immorality,
but not necessarily for
idolatry. Um, you know, the,
the gentile sailors even who worship
others are not necessarily punished.
And in fact,
it's said that they revere God and,
and they're reluctant to
throw this man overboard.
Other nations are not obligated
in the view of this book, um,
as in the early traditions of
genesis to accept monotheism,
but they're bound by a
certain basic moral law.
Maybe the moral law of
the Noaa Hide Covenant.
And it's for this that God
has decreed punishment.
So the theme where the basic problem in
this short book is the problem of God's
justice versus his mercy.
And Jonah is a champion of divine justice.
He believes that since should be punished,
he's outraged at God's forgiveness.
But Jonah learns that a change of heart
is enough to obtain mercy and that the
true role of the prophet is perhaps to
move people to reformation and turning.
What must have been the reception of
this book in the Post exhilarate period.
Again, not knowing exactly when it
was written. We can imagine, however,
and the way in the manner
of a canonical critic,
how it might've been perceived by people
in the post exhilarate period for whom
it would have become canonical.
The very idea of a profit
being sent to Nineveh,
Nineveh,
the capital of the hated Assyrian Empire,
the home of the people who had destroyed
the northern Kingdom of Israel and the
10 tribes of Israel and seven 22
dispersing those 10 tribes forever.
The,
uh,
the nation that had then laid siege to
Jerusalem and exact attribute from Judah
for many years.
This must have been startling.
And ultimately then this
book would represent a strand
of thought in post exilic
Judah that differed very much from the
eschatological fervor that delighted in
fantasies of the destruction
of Israel's enemies,
such as we found in Joel and as would
be featured later in Daniel and in post
biblical apocalyptic literature, most
notably the Christian book of revelation,
the book of Jonah reminded Israel that
the Universal God is desirous of the
reformation and the turning of all
his creation, human and animal,
and proposes that the Israelite Prophet
is called upon to carry a message of
divine forgiveness to other nations,
not just judgment,
even those that have humiliated
and despised God's chosen.
So wittingly or unwittingly,
we may never know, uh,
the author of this little satire fostered
the post Zelig sense of Israel as a
light unto the nations.
This is an idea that we've already
seen in some of the late, um,
prophetic writings.
Just a few words of conclusion.
The literature of the Hebrew Bible
relates the Odyssey of Israel from its
earliest beginnings in the stories
of Individual Patriarchs worshiping a
Canaanite,
uh,
to its maturity as a nation forced by
history to look beyond its own horizons
and concerns.
The Israelites were lifted up to become
something greater than they could ever
have planned,
and they came to see themselves as God's
servants to the world at the same time
that they struggled and argued with their
God and criticize themselves for their
very human weaknesses and failings.
And from another vantage point,
the Bible can be seen also as an anthology
that struggles against great odds to
sustain a people's covenantal
relationship with God.
The contrast between reality and the
religious moral ideal that good prospers
and evil is defeated was a distressing
and perplexing problem that occupied the
biblical writers, the existence of
evil, the suffering of the righteous,
the defeat of God's chosen.
All this seemed basically incompatible
with certain fundamental monotheistic
intuitions that God holds
supreme power in the universe,
that God is essentially good and just,
and his providential care
extends throughout creation.
How can faith in such a god be upheld
in the face of evil and suffering?
Although all ancient cultures and modern
cultures struggle with the problem of
evil,
it had particular poignancy for ancient
Israel in other ancient near eastern
literatures. We find out about the
existence of a moral order, certainly,
but only in Israel does the question of
evil touch on the very essence of God
and the very foundation
of religious faith.
Paganism posits the existence of
primordial evil demons or gods,
and thus the existence of evil and
suffering does not impugn the good God's
themselves.
Later religious systems that grow out
of the Bible will in fact increasingly
posit demons or a devil,
right? Second Temple,
Judaism later Rabbinic Judaism, and most
especially Christianity. We'll pause it,
some devil to account for evil in
the world, undeserved, suffering,
outrageous and frustrating as it might be,
can then be explained at least by the
jealousy or the caprice of the evil angels
or Gods or the demons or devil
who are indifferent to man's fate.
But in biblical religion,
there is no independent eval principle
and so undeserved suffering and rampant
evil impugn the goodness and justice of
God himself and Biblical persons have no
refuge from evil and suffering other
than faith and God's justice and if that
justice is slow in coming than
despair and doubt threatened.
For this reason,
Israelite theodicy I think is charged
with great pathos because the stakes are
so high. If one loses faith in
an essentially moral universe,
one loses God or at least as
we saw in the book of job,
one loses a god who governs the
world to a clear moral standard,
but the biblical writers don't
approach the problem as philosophers or
theologians might.
For the philosopher Theodicy,
the problem of evil is primarily a
logical problem. It's a contradiction.
How can adjust and good God allow evil
and suffering to exist in the world and
like any other logical problem,
it's best to solved according to the
philosophers and theologians through the
careful construction of
a systematic argument.
This is not the message or the approach
of the biblical writers. For them,
the problem is not philosophical,
it is personal. It is psychological.
It is spiritual.
The burning question is really this.
How can one sustain a commitment to
Israel's God in the face of national
catastrophe and personal suffering?
How can one have the strength to embrace,
to trust,
to love this God knowing
that unpredictable suffering
and chaos have struck and
may again strike at any moment and
various writers from various periods add
their voices to Israel,
struggle to come to terms with the problem
of sustaining faith in the midst of
evil and suffering.
The Bible's aim is not to
solve the philosophical
problem of theodicy so much as
it is to enable the relationship
with God to survive all shocks,
to make life in covenant with God,
a viable option despite the evil and the
suffering that are experienced by the
faithful.
The Bible doesn't offer one single
model of how to cope with this problem.
A dynamic relationship with what
is perceived to be a living,
personal god rather than the static God
of the philosophers is too complex to be
captured in a single dimensional theology.
Systematic theology could not do justice
to the very gated experiences of the
nation and of an individual,
a life.
And that's not the mode or genre
chosen by the biblical writers.
And so various models are presented,
not all consistent with one another,
but each serving a particular segment of
the community coping with a particular
challenge at a particular time and
each is an attempt to sustain Israel's
relationship with God in the face of
challenges to that continued relationship.
Biblical writers tell stories and they
interpret history in order to illustrate
the many ways in which various
individuals and the nation as a whole have
managed to make sense of the
covenantal relationship with God.
And there's room for multiple models,
multiple images of God and
his relationship to Israel.
And as modern readers of the Bible,
we can only marvel at this unresolved
polyphony in this ancient and theology.
It's as if the rabbis who were later to
canonize this collection saw the truth
and the words of Co Helen,
that to everything there is a season and
a time for every purpose under heaven.
And so they included books
with very different approaches.
To the fundamental problems that face
the ancient Israelites as Israelites and
as human beings.
So after 58065807586 BCE,
the deuteronomist salvaged.
Yeah.
Wisdom from going the way
of other defeated national
religions by arguing that
Israel had suffered,
not because God's promises weren't true,
but because they weren't believed.
And this enabled the Israelites
to continue faithful to their god.
Despite the destruction of his
sanctuary has chosen city and his ruler.
The profits emphasize the moral and
communal aspects of the covenant without
which all sacrificial
worship was anathema.
And so they unwittingly prepared the way
for a worship without sacrifice in the
diaspora.
And in later Judaism,
the psalms give expression to the deepest
emotions of the worship are struggling
with personal despair and anger or
brimming over with joy and faith.
Job gives vent to the outrage
we feel over unjust suffering.
While Ecclesiastes preaches existential
pleasures as a solace for the vanity of
all human endeavor,
Ezra and Nehemiah can confront the
very real problem of assimilation and
identity with a call to Israel to close
ranks while Jonah and Ruth remind Jews
of the universal providence of their
God and the power of repentance.
Esther and Daniel provide encouragement
of radically different types for Jews
under threat of persecution and massacre.
One,
a plea for self reliance in
solidarity and the other,
a promise of divine
intervention and an apocalypse.
Do all these books contradict each other?
No more than I contradict myself
when I say that today I feel happy,
but yesterday I felt anxious.
Israel's relationship with God has always
been a dynamic and a complex one and
two,
each of these books,
there was a time and a purpose in the
past and as countless readers of the Bible
have discovered over the centuries these
books offered continued teaching and
inspiration in the shifting
moments of every age.
Thank you very much for your
attention this semester.
Don't forget the review session that will
be held here with me next week from 10
30 to 1230 and you're early,
you get to go home
10 [inaudible].